Save now at Whole Foods Market. It's the Summer Splash event, with great everyday prices on 365 brand ground beef for the grill and ice cream for dessert. They have yellow sales signs on ready to cook beef or chicken kebabs too. Level up with savory marinate, spices and rubs, and complete your cookout with a crowd-pleasing cherry pie and their balsamic chicken salad. Available at the prepared foods counter. Get Summer Splash Savings now at Whole Foods Market. What causes stress? Money, work, illness? What about discrimination? Nearly half of Americans report they have experienced a major form of discrimination. These acts are associated with higher reported stress levels and poor health. That's according to the latest stress in America survey. In this episode, we speak with a psychologist about how different groups respond to stress and how best to cope. I'm Audrey Hamilton and this is speaking of psychology. Lynn Buffka is Associate Executive Director for Practice Research and Policy at the American Psychological Association.
立即在全食超市 (Whole Foods Market) 享受优惠。现在是夏季狂欢活动，365 品牌烤肉碎牛肉和饭后冰淇淋均享有超值日常优惠。熟食牛肉或鸡肉串也挂上了黄色促销标签。搭配美味的腌料、香料和干擦料，让烹饪升级，再配上一份老少咸宜的樱桃派和意大利香醋鸡肉沙拉，让你的烧烤派对更加完美。熟食柜台有售。立即在全食超市享受夏季狂欢优惠。什么导致了压力？金钱、工作、疾病？歧视呢？近一半的美国人表示他们经历过某种主要形式的歧视。这些行为与较高的压力水平和不良健康状况有关。这是根据最新的“美国压力”调查得出的结论。在本期节目中，我们将与一位心理学家探讨不同群体如何应对压力以及如何最好地应对压力。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是“心理学访谈”。林·巴夫卡是美国心理协会实践研究与政策副执行主任。
She was on a panel of experts who developed APA's 2016 Stress in America survey. A licensed psychologist, she is an expert in stress and mind-body health matters. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Buffka. Thank you for having me. Let's get right into the focus of this year's Stress in America survey, which looks at the link between discrimination and stress. And according to the report, 69% of adults in the U.S. report having experienced discrimination. 61% saying they experience day-to-day discrimination.
她曾是制定美国心理协会 2016 年“美国压力”调查的专家组成员。她是一名执业心理学家，也是压力和身心健康问题的专家。感谢您加入我们，巴夫卡博士。谢谢您邀请我。让我们直接切入今年“美国压力”调查的重点，该调查探讨了歧视与压力之间的联系。根据该报告，69% 的美国成年人表示曾经历过歧视。61% 的人表示他们经历了日常歧视。
When people are treated differently because of their race or sexual orientation or gender, for example, what effect does it have on their physical and mental health over time? Well, when people are treated differently, ideally, you know, we recognize experiences of discrimination as being not about us and recognize it as actually being discrimination or understand that it's the other person's, problematic behavior. But when it happens repeatedly, that's really hard to do. We start to internalize. Maybe there's something about us. Maybe it's me that's causing this to happen, or maybe there's something that's not quite right, or it can pick away at your self-esteem
例如，当人们因为种族、性取向或性别而受到不同对待时，随着时间的推移，会对他们的身心健康产生什么影响？嗯，当人们受到不同对待时，理想情况下，你知道，我们认识到歧视经历与我们无关，并认识到这实际上是歧视，或者明白这是另一个人的问题行为。但当这种情况重复发生时，这就很难做到了。我们开始内化。也许我们身上有什么问题。也许是我导致了这种情况的发生，或者也许有什么地方不太对劲，或者它会侵蚀你的自尊心
to repeatedly feel that you're the experience, the target of these things. You may start believing negative things about yourself that are consistent with the discrimination, or perhaps you'll even behave differently or avoid situations, even if those are love, activities or possible job opportunities or interesting classes you might want to take just because you don't want to be potentially in a situation where you could be experiencing discrimination. Sometimes you might even do things like you in a situation, but you're less reserved because you don't want to draw attention to yourself.
反复感到自己是这些事情的经历者、目标。你可能会开始相信与歧视一致的关于你自己的负面事情，或者甚至你可能会表现得不同或回避情况，即使这些是你喜爱的活动、可能的工作机会或你可能想上的有趣课程，只是因为你不想潜在地处于可能经历歧视的境地。有时你甚至可能会做一些事情，比如你身处某种情境中，但你表现得比较拘谨，因为你不想引起别人的注意。
So you may feel like you have to change your personality in order to not be the target of anything. And when you're changing your thinking or behavior like this and it doesn't feel consistent with who you are, that can lead to experiences of depression or anxiety. Certainly, it can be stressful, and one would experience it as being stress. And stress over time can have a very serious impact on the body. Why is it so important to look at how different groups experience this type of stress? We know that different groups report different experiences of stress. They can be stressed about different kinds of topics, or they report different levels of stress. But we know less about
所以你可能会觉得你必须改变你的性格，以免成为任何事情的目标。当你以这种方式改变你的思维或行为，并且觉得与真实的自己不一致时，这可能会导致抑郁或焦虑的体验。当然，这可能会产生压力，人们会将其体验为压力。随着时间的推移，压力会对身体产生非常严重的影响。为什么研究不同群体如何体验这种类型的压力如此重要？我们知道，不同群体报告的压力体验不同。他们可能对不同类型的话题感到压力，或者他们报告的压力水平不同。但我们对以下方面的了解较少
what these different experiences of stress mean for each of these groups. groups. Does it place certain groups at greater risk for disease? Does it lead to certain kinds of behavior patterns that are problematic? There's certainly some evidence that racial and ethnic discrimination places people at greater risk for certain health problems. But we know very little about how different groups might actually cope with stress, too. While there's a lot of different individual responses to stress, if there are group differences, we may be able to target interventions and education more effectively. We might be able to identify key sources of stress and modify those. When the source of stress is something like discrimination, sure, we want to
这些不同的压力体验对每个群体意味着什么。它是否会让某些群体面临更高的疾病风险？它是否会导致某种有问题行为模式的出现？当然有一些证据表明，种族和族裔歧视使人们面临更高某些健康问题的风险。但对于不同群体实际上如何应对压力，我们也知之甚少。虽然对压力有许多不同的个人反应，但如果有群体差异，我们也许能够更有效地针对干预措施和教育。我们或许能够识别压力的关键来源并对其进行修改。当压力的来源类似于歧视时，当然，我们希望
help people who are being discriminated against figure out how to manage their response, but we also want to think about how do we change the discrimination so that they're not experiencing it. So we do want to understand both what the individual is experiencing, but how groups are experiencing it so we know where to target our efforts. It seems many people are uncomfortable discussing racial differences, especially with children. How can parents and other adults address topics of diversity and discrimination with children of all ages? Kids notice differences. They notice when people are treated differently. And discussing these differences openly in a non-judgmental way allows kids to have the space to ask the questions that they're coming up with. And ideally, parents and other adults can help
帮助遭受歧视的人弄清楚如何管理他们的反应，但我们也想考虑如何改变歧视，让他们不再经历歧视。所以我们确实既想了解个人正在经历什么，也想了解群体是如何经历的，这样我们就知道把精力集中在哪里。似乎许多人对讨论种族差异感到不舒服，尤其是与儿童一起。父母和其他成年人如何与所有年龄段的儿童探讨多样性和歧视等话题？孩子们会注意到差异。他们会注意到人们何时受到不同的对待。以非评判的方式公开讨论这些差异，可以让孩子们有空间提出他们想到的问题。理想情况下，父母和其他成年人可以帮助
children to value the differences that people have, as well as recognizing what they have in common. When adults are going to have these conversations with kids, they need to keep in mind both the age of the child and the developmental stage so they know how best to respond. Younger children probably need simpler, more basic conversations, but with opportunities to ask questions and talk about things. Middle school kids, a lot of times information and facts are of a lot of interest to them. With teenagers, you want to have as much opportunity for exploration discussion with them because they're going to have their own. own ideas and opinions about what's happening and what they've observed. But at any point, adults should be prepared for surprising or challenging comments or questions. And with any conversation with kids, it's okay to admit our mistakes when perhaps maybe we did treat someone differently or maybe we
孩子们珍视人与人之间的差异，并认识到他们的共同点。当成年人要与孩子们进行这些对话时，他们需要牢记孩子的年龄和发展阶段，以便知道如何做出最好的回应。较小的孩子可能需要更简单、更基础的对话，但要有提问和谈论事情的机会。对于中学生来说，很多时候信息和事实对他们很有吸引力。对于青少年，你希望尽可能多地与他们进行探索讨论，因为他们对正在发生的事情和他们所观察到的事情会有自己的想法和意见。但在任何时候，成年人都应该为令人惊讶或具有挑战性的评论或问题做好准备。在与孩子们的任何对话中，承认我们的错误是可以的，也许我们确实对某人进行了不同的对待，或者也许我们
failed to stand up to an experience of discrimination and we wished we could have done it differently. That can really go a long way in opening a conversation with the child. But I think another question that's important to consider is what if your child is aware of differences and feels like he or she's being discriminated against or simply being treated differently. It's really important for the adults in their life to acknowledge that that could be their reality. It's appropriate to share your own experiences if you've had such experiences. You talk about what it means, how your child can respond if that happens again. You don't want to dwell on it, but you certainly don't want to dismiss it either. In past years, APA's stress in America's survey has
未能勇敢面对歧视经历，而我们希望当时能做得不同。这在开启与孩子的对话时大有帮助。但我认为另一个需要考虑的重要问题是，如果你的孩子意识到差异，并且觉得他或她受到歧视或仅仅受到不同的对待，那会怎样？对于他们生活中的成年人来说，承认这可能是他们的现实非常重要。如果你有过这样的经历，分享你自己的经历是恰当的。你谈论这意味着什么，如果再次发生这种情况，你的孩子该如何回应。你不想纠缠于此，但也绝对不想置之不理。在过去几年里，美国心理协会的“美国压力”调查一直
consistently concluded that Americans are more stressed about finances than anything else. Money continues to be a significant source of stress. Was this consistent in other groups across different groups? What can people do about money-related stress? Money has been a significant source of stress in almost every survey we've done over the years. And it doesn't really matter who's responding, whether we divide it by different racial ethnic groups, men and women. If we look at different ages, about the only time we're not.
一致得出结论，美国人对财务的压力比对其他任何事情都大。金钱仍然是压力的一个重要来源。在不同群体的其他群体中，这种一致性是否存在？人们能对与金钱相关的压力做些什么？在我们多年来进行的几乎每一次调查中，金钱一直是压力的重要来源。不管是谁在回应，无论是按不同的种族族裔群体划分，还是按男女划分。如果我们看看不同的年龄，几乎唯一的一次我们没有看到
we see money not being a top source of stress, the top source of stress, is with the matures, the oldest demographic in our sample, and they're more often reporting stress about health concerns. But everyone is talking about money-related stress. And sometimes the reality is there just isn't enough money. And when that's the case, figuring out how to get assistance so you can cover the basics, whether you need public assistance or talking with family or getting loans, that's really important.
我们看到金钱不是首要压力来源，首要压力来源是成熟一代，即我们样本中最年长的群体，他们更常报告对健康问题的压力。但每个人都在谈论与金钱相关的压力。有时现实是根本没有足够的资金。在这种情况下，弄清楚如何获得援助以便你能支付基本费用，无论你需要公共援助、与家人交谈还是获得贷款，这真的很重要。
And then the next kind of money stress is sometimes related to what we think we need or what we think we should have. We might have the money for basics, but we want other things as well. So then we need to start evaluating how we use and manage money and the choices we make with money because our perceptions of what we need and want and desire may not match with what we actually have. So shifting our perceptions and trying to understand where we're actually spending our money. How does that fit with what we value?
然后，下一种金钱压力有时与我们认为我们需要的东西或我们认为我们应该拥有的东西有关。我们可能有基本生活的钱，但我们也想要其他东西。因此，我们需要开始评估我们如何使用和管理金钱以及我们在金钱上做出的选择，因为我们对我们需要、想要和渴望的 percibciones 可能与我们实际拥有的不匹配。因此，改变我们的感知并试图了解我们实际上把钱花在了哪里。这与我们所珍视的是如何契合的？
and trying to make those be more consistent. Budgeting is very important when you're talking about, do I have enough money or not? And what is it that I think is needed? Do I need the luxury car or an economy car? There's choices that we make when people talk about money stress. Sometimes it's about covering the basics, but sometimes it's about what's my status with money
并努力使它们更加一致。当你谈论我是否有足够的钱时，预算非常重要。我认为什么是必需的？我需要豪华车还是经济型车？当人们谈论金钱压力时，我们会做出选择。有时是关于支付基本费用，但有时是关于我在金钱方面的地位
and where do I have with it. People have complicated relationships with money. For some individuals, how much they earn, has a lot to do with how they feel about themselves and their own personal worth. And if that's some of the money stress that a person's feeling, they really need to evaluate that and sort of make sure that money's not defining who they are. Other things that are important to do are talk to family members about the money that you have and the stress you might have about that money.
以及我在其中的位置。人们与金钱有着复杂的关系。对某些个人而言，他们赚多少钱与他们对自己的感觉以及他们自身的个人价值有很大关系。如果这就是一个人感受到的金钱压力的一部分，他们真的需要评估这一点，并确保金钱不会定义他们是谁。其他重要的事情是与家庭成员谈论你拥有的金钱以及你可能对这些金钱产生的压力。
Maybe your partner doesn't know the full financial situation. Or maybe your kids have unrealistic expectations and make a lot of demands. Talk with them about what's reasonable. So it's trying to be more aware of what your financial situation actually is, how that maps on to what your needs and values are, and manage your own personal expectations about what money means, what money should buy for you to make it more consistent with the money that you have. But it is tough when you don't have the money for the basics. No doubt about that. That is stress. As a licensed psychologist, you treat people who are dealing with stress of all kinds. You talked a little bit about this, but is all stress bad, which is considered bad stress, which is considered good stress? And what sort of advice do you give to people who are experiencing this high levels of the bad stress?
也许你的伴侣并不了解全部的财务状况。或者也许你的孩子有不切实际的期望并提出很多要求。与他们谈谈什么是合理的。因此，这是为了更加意识到你的实际财务状况是什么，这如何映射到你的需求和价值观上，并管理你对自己金钱意味着什么、金钱应该为你买什么的个人期望，使其与你拥有的金钱更加一致。但是，当你没有基本生活的钱时，这确实很难。毫无疑问。这就是压力。作为一名执业心理学家，你治疗各种各样的压力患者。你对此进行了一些讨论，但所有的压力都是不好的吗，哪些被认为是坏压力，哪些被认为是好压力？对于经历这种高水平坏压力的人，你有什么样的建议？
You know, stress happens all the time. We talk in this country about being stressed for everything. Stress can happen. We can be excited about planning a wedding, but feel stressed because of all the pieces we're trying to pull together. We might feel stressed about an upcoming exam. but that stress might actually motivate us to study for the exam. So those are not necessarily bad stress. I think of bad stress, problematic stress,
你知道，压力一直都在发生。我们在这个国家谈论对一切事情都感到压力。压力可能会发生。我们可能会对策划一场婚礼感到兴奋，但由于我们要拼凑的所有碎片而感到压力。我们可能会对即将到来的考试感到压力，但这种压力实际上可能会激励我们为考试学习。所以这些不一定是坏压力。我认为坏压力、有问题的压力是
is when the demands that you're feeling outmatch your ability to deal with them. You just don't have the resources to cope with whatever the situation is. That's when stress is really becoming problematic. And when you have that amount of stress where you're feeling that your personal resources, psychological, emotional, social, resource, outstrip the demands on your life. A lot of things can happen. Physiologically, your body gets more ramped up and you might have
当你感受到的需求超出了你应对它们的能力时。你根本没有资源来应付无论什么情况。那就是压力真正开始变得有问题的时候。当你承受着这种程度的压力，感觉到你的个人资源（心理、情感、社会资源）超出了你生活中的需求时。很多事情都会发生。从生理上讲，你的身体会变得更加亢奋，你可能会有
more experiences of racing heart. You might have trouble digesting food. It can play havoc with your blood sugar. There's all kinds of physiological changes that can happen. Muscle tension, all kinds of mental and emotional strain that a person can experience. And when a person gets to that point, reaching out for support, sometimes it can be support from family or friends, but sometimes you realize I need some support from a professional. And if I'm seeing somebody who's really struggling with a lot of stress, we talk about how are they thinking about the things in their lives? Are they filling themselves up with a lot of musts and shoulds and absolutes? And things would only be better if, but that if is awfully hard to attain.
更多的频繁心跳体验。你可能会有消化食物的困难。它会破坏你的血糖。各种生理变化都可能发生。肌肉紧张，一个人可以经历各种心理和情感压力。当一个人达到那个点时，寻求支持，有时它可以来自家人或朋友的支持，但有时你会意识到我需要来自专业人士的一些支持。如果我看到有人真的在承受大量压力中挣扎，我们会谈论他们如何看待生活中的事物？他们是否用大量的必须、应该和绝对来充实自己？而且事情只会变得更好，但那个如果非常难以达到。
And we talk about how can we think about the situations in a way that's a little more realistic and less demanding on the person themselves. But we also talk about things like how do you balance your life? Do you know how to say no? Do you turn down things that seem to be excessive? Do you do things that give you pleasure and help you relax and enjoy? You know, I tell new parents a lot of times, if you don't take care of yourself, you can't take care of your child very well. It's important to give yourself some downtime when you can find that in your day. And people find that very difficult, but part of what I do is strategize with them about how to do that. I worked with somebody who was very stressed with her work situation, and we considered three questions. We thought
我们讨论如何以更现实、对个人自身要求更少的方式来思考情况。但我们也讨论诸如你如何平衡你的生活之类的事情？你知道如何说不吗？你是否拒绝那些似乎过分的事情？你做那些能给你带来快乐、帮助你放松和享受的事情吗？你知道，我经常对新父母说，如果你不照顾好自己，你就不能很好地照顾你的孩子。当你能在一天中找到的时候，给自己一些停机时间是很重要的。人们发现这非常困难，但我工作的一部分是与他们一起制定如何做到这一点的策略。我曾与一位对工作环境感到非常压力的女士合作，我们考虑了三个问题。我们想
about could she do something differently and how she responded to the demands in her work? Could she change the demands at her work? And ultimately, she decided to go with the third option, which was to leave her work and find a new job, because she felt she'd done many things to change her responses to the stress. She didn't think she could change the work environment. so she determined she needed a new position. And those are all things we need to think through. Am I responding to stress in a way that is amplifying it, or am I managing it a way that I can let it go and walk away from it at times?
关于她是否可以做些不同的事情以及她如何应对工作中的要求？她能改变工作中的要求吗？最终，她决定选择第三个选项，那就是离开她的工作并找到一份新工作，因为她觉得她已经做很多事情来改变她对压力的反应。她认为她无法改变工作环境，所以她决定她需要一个新职位。这些都是我们需要深思熟虑的事情。我是以一种放大的方式对压力做出反应，还是以一种我可以让它过去并有时远离它的方式来管理它？
Can I change the situation in some way, or do I need to leave the situation in order to be less stressed? And those are all important things to think about. And they're not easy. And talking with a professional can help you think through your options and challenge how you're thinking about situations and also learn things about how to manage the physical changes that can happen with stress, whether you learn meditation or relaxation or think about other ways to help your body reduce its
我能以某种方式改变现状，还是需要离开现状以减少压力？这些都是需要思考的重要事情。它们并不容易。与专业人士交谈可以帮助你理清你的选择，并挑战你对情况的看法，还可以学习如何管理随压力而来的生理变化，无论你学习冥想还是放松，或者考虑其他方法来帮助你的身体减少其
responsibility to stress. What can happen if you don't address these issues, and we're talking about the high levels of bad stress, what health implications could be a result of that? It's interesting on the APA HELP Center. We have a really neat graphic of a human body. And it shows all the different domains in the body that can be impacted by stress. So a person can, if their body physiologically is being really reactive to stress, the heart rate may go up. They may be breathing more erratically.
如果你不解决这些问题会发生什么，我们正在谈论高水平的坏压力，这可能会导致什么样的健康影响？有趣的是，在美国心理协会健康中心。我们有一个非常漂亮的巨大人体图形。它展示了受压力影响的身体中的所有不同领域。因此，如果一个人的身体在生理上对压力反应非常强烈，心率可能会上升。他们的呼吸可能会更不稳定。
They may feel lightheaded because of that. They may have muscle tension a lot. So they may feel very stiff and have body aches. Their heart may be racing more. They may have an increase in the stress hormones. You know, the cortisol, which can have an impact on the body over time. time. There does seem to be some relationship between chronic physical health conditions and stress as well as between anxiety and depression and stress. So all of that unchecked over time
由于这一点，他们可能会感到头晕。他们可能会经常肌肉紧张。所以他们可能会感到非常僵硬并且身体疼痛。他们的心脏可能会跳得更快。他们的压力荷尔蒙可能会增加。你知道，皮质醇，随着时间的推移，它会对身体产生影响。慢性身体健康状况与压力之间，以及焦虑、抑郁与压力之间似乎确实存在某种关系。因此，所有这些随着时间的推移没有得到控制
can have a pretty profound impact on a person's life. Okay, Dr. Buffka, thank you so much for joining us. You're welcome. Thank you for having me. To see the latest stress in America report and to hear more podcast episodes, please go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association. Speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
会对一个人的生活产生相当深远的影响。好的，巴夫卡博士，非常感谢您加入我们。不客气。谢谢您邀请我。要查看最新的“美国压力”报告并收听更多播客剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理协会的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。